Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
d’une expérience fondamentale de la mécanique
quantique, qui illustre à elle seule plusieurs
aspects essentiels et contre-intuitifs du
monde quantique : il s’agit de l’expérience
de Stern et Gerlach, du nom des deux physiciens
allemands qui l’ont réalisée pour la première
fois il y a un siècle, en 1922.
Quand on pense aux expériences fondatrices
de la mécanique quantique, on pense souvent
en premier aux expériences d’interférences
avec des électrons, en utilisant les fentes
d’Young.
Et c’est vrai qu’elles permettent de capturer
de façon très visuelle beaucoup d’aspects
de la mécanique quantique, d’ailleurs je
vous renvoie à la vidéo que j’avais faite
sur ce sujet.
Mais l’expérience de Stern & Gerlach, dont
on va parler aujourd’hui, est tout aussi
importante.
Et ce qui intéressant, c’est qu’elle
permet d’illustrer certains phénomènes
quantiques sous un angle différent, et donc
très complémentaire de ce qu’on peut voir
avec les expériences d’interférences.
Ce que je vais vous présenter ici est une
version un peu idéalisée, modernisée, de
l’expérience, telle qu’on pourrait la
refaire aujourd’hui avec des moyens expérimentaux
meilleurs que ceux dont disposaient les deux
physiciens allemands il y a un siècle.
[DISPOSITIF Imaginez que l’on dispose d’une
boite percée d’un petit trou, et que par
ce trou soit émis un faisceau de particules.
Dans l’expérience d’origine, il s’agissait
d’atomes d’argent qui sortaient d’un
four, mais en fait la nature exacte des particules
pourrait être différente.
Sur la trajectoire du faisceau, on va placer
un champ magnétique bien uniforme, et derrière
un écran pour repérer à quel endroit viennent
taper les particules.
Alors qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer ?
Vous savez peut-être qu’un champ magnétique
ça agit sur les particules chargées.
Il y a une formule pour ça, qui exprime la
force exercée, c’est la force de Lorentz.
Et on voit dans cette formule que si la particule
n’est pas chargée, ben il n’y aura pas
de force, facile.
Si on fait comme Stern et Gerlach et qu’on
utilise des atomes, qui sont donc globalement
neutres, le champ magnétique n’a pas d’effet,
et donc toutes les particules viennent taper
au centre de l’écran qu’on a placé.
Ah oui je ne l’ai pas dit mais dans cette
trajectoire on peut ignorer les effets de
la gravité.
Les particules dans le faisceau ont une vitesse
importante, plusieurs centaines de mètres
par seconde, et donc elles sont à peine affectées
le temps du trajet.]
Jusqu’ici rien d’incroyable, maintenant
variante : on va utiliser un champ magnétique
qui n’est plus uniforme, mais qui est par
exemple plus fort en haut qu’en bas, et
ce de façon progressive.
On parle d’un champ magnétique avec un
gradient.
[DISPOSITIF Et là quand on fait l’expérience,
première surprise, on constate que les particules
sont déviées par ce champ magnétique.
Si le champ magnétique est dirigé selon
l’axe vertical, appelons-le l’axe Z, les
particules vont être déviées certaines
vers le haut, d’autres vers le bas.]
A première vue ça peut paraitre étonnant.
On l’a dit les atomes sont neutres, on ne
s’attend donc pas à ce qu’ils soient
sensibles au champ magnétique.
Pourquoi quand le champ magnétique n’est
plus uniforme cela provoque une déviation
? Eh bien c’est ce qu’il se passerait
si au lieu de balancer des atomes on balançait
des petits aimants.
[AIMANTS Si vous prenez un aimant, je vais
représenter ça avec l’image familière
des pôles nord et sud, et que vous l’envoyez
ainsi dans un champ magnétique non-uniforme,
qui a un gradient, eh bien l’aimant va être
dévié, c’est un effet magnétique bien
connu.
Et l’intensité de la déviation va dépendre
de deux choses : la puissance de l’aimant,
et son orientation par rapport à l’axe
de variation du champ, ici l’axe vertical
Z.
Si vous alignez les pôles dans l’axe de
la trajectoire, ils sont perpendiculaire à
l’axe Z, et il n’y aura pas de déviation.
Et sinon la déviation sera vers le bas ou
vers le haut suivant l’orientation.
Dans notre cas les déviations maximales sont
obtenues quand l’aimant est parfaitement
aligné avec la direction de variation du
champ.
Et évidemment tout ça est aussi proportionnel
à la taille et la force de l’aimant, un
aimant plus puissant serait dévié de façon
plus importante.
Pour représenter cette combinaison des caractéristiques
de l’aimant et de son orientation, on utilise
une quantité physique qu’on appelle le
moment magnétique.
C’est un vecteur, et on s’en sert pour
représenter l’aimant à l’aide d’une
flèche qui pointe vers son pôle nord, et
qui est d’autant plus longue que l’aimant
est puissant.
On va noter ce vecteur M, comme «Moment
magnétique». Avec cette représentation,
pour savoir à quel point l’aimant est dévié,
ce qu’on va regarder c’est simplement
la composante de ce vecteur sur l’axe Z.
On note cette composante Mz.
M est un vecteur, mais Mz est juste un nombre
réel, positif ou négatif.
Pour des aimants à peu près alignés avec
l’axe Z, Mz sera important, et on aura une
forte déviation vers le haut ou vers le bas.
Et dans le cas perpendiculaire, la composante
Mz est nulle, et on n’aura pas de déviation.
Voilà, tout ça c’est pour des aimants
dont on connait le moment magnétique M.]
Et donc revenons à l’expérience de Stern
et Gerlarch.
Si on constate que les atomes qu’on envoie
dans ce champ magnétique sont aussi déviés,
cela signifie simplement qu’ils se comportent
comme des aimants.
C’est quelque chose qui n’était pas forcément
inattendu à l’époque, c’était même
ce qu’espéraient voir Stern et Gerlach,
mais il y a eu une surprise de taille.
[TACHES Si les atomes se comportent effectivement
comme des petits aimants, qu’il possèdent
un moment magnétique, on peut s’attendre
à ce quand il sortent de la boite pour former
le faisceau, l’orientation de leur moment
magnétique soit quelconque, qu’il y en
ait dans tous les sens.
D’ailleurs ici je la représente seulement
en 2D pour faire simple, mais il faudrait
le faire en 3D.
Et comme la déviation va dépendre de l’orientation,
on devrait détecter des impacts un peu partout
sur l’écran : au centre, en haut, en bas,
en fonction de l’orientation de nos atomes-aimants.
On peut même en principe deviner de la répartition
des impacts : pas mal d’impacts au centre,
moins quand on va vers les extrêmes.
Et pas du tout au delà d’un certain seuil.
Sauf que ça n’est pas du tout ce que Stern
et Gerlach ont observé : au lieu de ça,
ils ont constaté que les impacts formaient
deux tâches bien localisées en haut et en
bas.
Et rien au centre.
C’est très bizarre.
On l’a dit normalement pour un aimant la
déviation est liée à Mz, la composante
du moment magnétique sur l’axe vertical.
Donc dans l’expérience, c’est comme si
les particules avaient effectivement un moment
magnétique, mais que sa composante Mz ne
puisse prendre que deux valeurs bien définies,
opposées, l’une positive et l’autre négative.
Mais aucune des valeurs intermédiaires, et
en particulier c’est jamais zéro ou presque.
A partir de la position des deux tâches,
et en utilisant les caractéristiques de l’expérience,
sa taille, la vitesse des particules, etc.
on pourrait en déduire la valeur du moment
magnétique Mz.
Le dispositif qu’on vient de décrire, l’appareil
de Stern et Gerlach, permet de mesurer le
moment magnétique des particules selon un
axe, ici Mz.
La valeur exacte n’est pas forcément critique
ici, l’unité est un peu inhabituelle, ce
sont des ampères-mètre carré, et pour faire
simple, on va juste appeler ces deux valeurs
+1 et -1.
Les particules qui ont tapé en haut ont un
moment magnétique Mz=+1, et celle en bas
Mz=-1.]
Le fait qu’on ait uniquement ces deux valeurs
possibles illustre parfaitement un phénomène
qui est caractéristique de la mécanique
quantique, et qui lui donne même son nom
: c’est la quantification.
Il s’agit du fait que certaines propriétés
des objets quantiques, ici Mz, sont quantifiées.
Elle ne peuvent pas prendre n’importe quelle
valeur en continu, comme c’est le cas classiquement.
Mais elle sont limitées à un ensemble de
valeurs discrètes, ici seulement deux valeurs
possibles -1 et +1.
Vous savez peut-être que c’est le genre
de phénomène qu’on observe par exemple
avec les niveaux d’énergie de l’atome
d’hydrogène, qui sont eux aussi quantifiés.
Mais là c’est pas un niveau d’énergie,
c’est la composante d’un vecteur selon
un certain axe.
Se dire qu’une quantité géométrique soit
soumise à cet effet de ce genre, c’est
carrément bizarre.
Ici le choix de l’axe Z est totalement arbitraire,
j’aurai pu prendre n’importe quoi d’autre.
Et j’aurai trouvé +1 ou -1 quel que soit
l’axe.
Géométriquement ça n’a aucun sens, essayez
de me dessiner un vecteur dont la composante
selon n’importe quel axe soit toujours 1
ou -1.
Alors on va essayer de creuser cette idée,
mais avant ça un point important pour la
suite.
[DEUXIEME Si on ne met pas d’écran pour
visualiser les impacts, ce qu’il se passe
c’est qu’on sépare simplement le faisceau
initial en deux faisceaux en fonction de la
valeur de Mz.
Vers le haut le faisceau Mz=+1 et vers le
bas Mz=-1.
Maintenant si utilise un deuxième appareil
identique, qu’on le place sur chacun des
deux faisceaux, eh bien là on ne verra plus
de séparation.
Les particules qui étaient initialement déviées
vers le haut vont toutes à nouveau être
déviées vers le haut, et pareil pour celle
qui étaient déviées vers le bas.]
C’est assez logique.
On l’a dit dans cette expérience, on peut
voir le dispositif comme un appareil de mesure.
Il permet de connaitre la valeur de Mz, et
de savoir si c’est -1 ou +1 et de trier
les particules.
Et si on répète la mesure, eh bien on obtient
à nouveau la même déviation.
C’est rassurant.
[FAISCEAU Et donc tout ça laisse penser que
dans notre faisceau initial, il y avait des
atomes à Mz = +1 et d’autres à Mz = -1,
et qu’on les a séparé en deux grâce au
dispositif.]
Maintenant on l’a dit, tout ça concerne
la composante selon l’axe vertical Z.
Mais le vecteur moment magnétique M, il a
évidemment d’autres composantes sur les
autres axes.
Considérons par exemple l’axe Y, celui
qui serait perpendiculaire au plan de la figure.
[AXE Y On peut réaliser un dispositif qui
va mesurer la composante My, il suffit de
changer la direction de variation du champ
magnétique, et si on fait ça on observe
exactement la même chose, une séparation
en deux faisceaux : un pour My=+1 et un pour
My=-1.]
Et on pourrait faire pareil avec l’axe
X mais faisons simple et restons en deux dimensions.
[VECTEUR Pris littéralement, ces résultats
semble dire que le vecteur moment magnétique
ne peut prendre que 4 valeurs suivant que
My et Mz valent +1 ou -1.
Voici ce qu’on pourrait imaginer.
Ce qui est bizarre on l’a dit, c’est que
géométriquement ça n’a aucun sens.
On pourrait penser avec ça que le vecteur
M est toujours aligné sur la diagonale des
axes Y et Z.
Sauf qu’ici les axes Y et Z ici sont complètement
arbitraires, ils ont été choisis pour l’expérience.
Mais on aurait pu les choisir tournés de
10, 20 ou 30°, et on aurait eu exactement
les mêmes résultats.]
Pour s’en sortir, il faut renoncer à interpréter
le moment magnétique M comme un vecteur géométrique
normal, dont les composantes sur les différents
axes, comme My ou Mz, auraient une valeur
bien définie.
Et pour le voir, on va utiliser une nouvelle
variante du montage.
[3 APPAREILS Prenons un premier appareil qui
sépare en deux faisceau selon Mz, donc qui
mesure Mz, puis installons derrière le même
mais pour mesurer My, puis enfin à nouveau
une mesure de Mz.
On l’a dit normalement quand on mesure deux
fois de suite la même quantité on obtient
le même résultat…mais pas ici.
Si par exemple on ne regarde que le faisceau
initial Mz=+1 après le premier appareil,
on s’attendrait quand on le re-mesure avec
le troisième appareil, après la mesure de
My, on ait toujours uniquement des Mz=+1.
Mais non, on trouve à nouveau deux faisceaux
correspondant à Mz = +1 et Mz = -1.
On croyait avoir déterminé la valeur de
Mz après le premier appareil, et sélectionné
uniquement les particules Mz=+1, mais le fait
de mesurer leur My juste après a complètement
brouillé les cartes, et rendu leur valeur
de Mz complètement indéterminée.]
On peut interpréter cela grâce à la notion
de superposition qu’on a évoqué dans la
vidéo précédente.
[SUPERPOSITION En sortie du premier appareil,
si on garde uniquement le faisceau du haut,
tous les atomes ont une valeur unique bien
définie pour Mz.
On dit qu’ils sont dans un état «propre»
de Mz.
«Propre» ça veut dire en gros qu’il
n’y a pas de phénomène de superposition
quantité pour cette quantité.
De façon similaire, le deuxième appareil
mesure My, donc il va mettre les atomes dans
un état propre de My soit My=-1 soit My=+1,
mais pas une superposition des deux.
Mais ce qu’on constate avec le troisième
appareil c’est que les particules ne sont
plus dans un état propre de Mz.
Même si on ne garde que celles qui étaient
par exemple Mz=+1, on obtient à nouveau deux
faisceaux Mz=+1 et Mz=-1.
On l’interprète en disant que les particules
sont revenus dans un état superposé pour
Mz.
Chaque particule est dans un état qui est
une superposition de Mz=-1 et Mz=+1.
Le passage dans le troisième appareil va
forcer l’une ou l’autre de ses possibilités
pour chaque particule.]
On voit avec cette seule expérience plusieurs
caractéristiques importantes des systèmes
quantiques : tout d’abord la mesure affecte
irrémédiablement l’état du système en
le mettant dans un état propre de la quantité
qu’on mesure.
Mais surtout cette notion d’état propre
ou superposé n’est pas absolue, elle est
relative et elle dépend de la quantité qu’on
mesure.
[COMMUTATION Ici quand la valeur Mz est connue,
on n’est dans un état propre pour Mz mais
qui s’avère être un état superposé pour
My, et réciproquement.
En sortie du deuxième appareil, on a un état
propre pour My, mais qui est un état superposé
pour Mz.
Impossible d’être dans un état propre
pour les deux quantités à la fois.
On dit que les deux quantité ne commutent
pas, ou que leur mesure ne commutent pas.
Vous savez en maths la commutativité c’est
quand l’ordre de l’opération n’a pas
d’importance.
L’addition est commutative car A+B = B+A.
Idem pour la multiplication.
Ici les opérations de mesure des composantes
du moment magnétique ne commutent pas : si
on mesure Mz on ne sait plus rien sur My,
et réciproquement.
L’ordre a donc son importance.]
Vous noterez que ça ressemble furieusement
à ce qu’on appelle ailleurs le principe
d’incertitude d’Heisenberg.
Ce principe nous dit, notamment, que quand
la position d’une particule est parfaitement
déterminée sa vitesse ne l’est plus du
tout et réciproquement.
Et que plus on connait l’une, moins on connait
l’autre.
Eh bien ce principe d’incertitude est en
fait plus général, ça n’est pas seulement
la position et la vitesse.
Dès qu’on a deux propriétés physiques
dont les mesures ne commutent pas, elles sont
soumises à une relation du même type.
Connaitre Mz rend My complètement indéterminé,
et réciproquement.
Vous voyez donc que, bien qu’elle soit moins
connue que l’expérience des interférences
d’électrons, l’expérience de Stern et
Gerlach permet d’illustrer de façon assez
minimale plusieurs principes de la mécanique
quantique : la quantification, la superposition,
l’impact d’une mesure sur l’état du
système, et une forme du principe d’incertitude.
Pour être complets, il faudrait creuser encore
l’interprétation de cette expérience,
et expliquer en quoi elle a aussi permis de
mettre en évidence un concept très important
: la notion de spin.
Mais cette interprétation n’a pris corps
que quelques années après l’expérience
initiale, et je vais garder ça pour un prochain
épisode.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, comme
toujours deux ou trois compléments sont à
retrouver sur le blog.
N’oubliez pas de vous abonner et mettre
la satanée cloche pour ne rien rater des
prochains épisodes de la chaine, sur la mécanique
quantique ou sur autre chose, et moi je vous
dit à très vite pour une prochaine vidéo.
A bientôt.
POSE MINIATURE.